three flights complete zero 5:22 make a
zero certain vertical and also expect
the city rescue one six zero which is a
ramp
c-130j system research
it is credible enough to divert the
research to this area on the basis it
provides a promising lead to what might
be wreckage from the debris field
almost two weeks into the search for
flight mh370 and a dramatic development
at 10 o'clock this morning the Prime
Minister received a call from the Prime
Minister of Australia informing him that
two possible objects related to the
search for mh370
has been identified in the southern
Indian Ocean this is potentially the
most significant breakthrough in finding
the missing airliner and knowing for
certain what has happened to the 239
people on board
could this satellite image help to solve
one of the greatest aviation mysteries
of modern times AMS's Rescue
Coordination Center Australia has
received satellite imagery of objects
possibly related to the search for the
missing aircraft flight mh370 RCC
Australia received an expert assessment
of that satellite imagery this morning
20th of March the images were captured
by satellite they may not be related to
the aircraft the assessment of these
images was provided by the Australian
geospatial intelligence organization as
a possible indication of debris south of
the search area that has been the focus
of the southern search operation since
Monday 17th of March one of the two
large objects measures 24 metres that's
almost seventy nine feet the other is
five metres some 15 feet the sizes fit
with what could be wreckage from an
airline and where they were spotted in
the southern Indian Ocean seems to match
the theory of a Southern Corridor one of
two possible diverted flight paths for
the missing aircraft it all makes this a
credible discovery Air Force planes from
Australia and New Zealand have been
dispatched from Perth to the suspected
debris field
the search by air is being bolstered by
a fleet on the sea the Royal Navy's 18
mass echo is enroute to the search area
the coastal survey vessel has multi-beam
sonar that could be utilized to listen
out for the black box and a Norwegian
ship has arrived in the area to help
with the search we have a vessel with 9
p.m. with experienced skills seafarers
on board they are all from the
Philippines employed by the complain
through our own office there the captain
he has been employed in her Val vanish
for 27 years so I'm all of them they are
known participating in order to do
search and rescue operation in the best
possible way family and loved ones have
had their hopes raised and dashed too
many times in the two harrowing weeks
since the passenger jet disappeared so
now the language is tempered this is a
lead it's not proof of the aircraft's
fate all the sensors that we have
available are maximized to detect any
debris life rafts or any potential
wreckage
come across it from the relation
airline's father we are
locate very very remote in the
southwestern part of the Indian Ocean
probably about 1,500 nautical miles to
the southwest of
so very remote
and a very large expansive area that we
need to search for anxiously waiting
relatives the news brings conflicting
emotion it's possibly an end to the two
weeks of not knowing but if this is the
wreckage from the flight it brings with
it a certainty that they may never see
their loved ones again but in Australia
we are still waiting for the results of
forensic examination by the Australian
government if it turns out that it is
mh370 then we will accept that we cannot
expect much because it has not been
confirmed we do not yet know for sure
whether this is indeed mh370 or
something else but they will have to
endure a further agonizing wait bad
weather is hampering the search effort
visibility is poor and finding the
suspected debris is proving to be a
challenge this is the cockpit view from
one of the first planes to scour the
area it gives you an idea of the task
that lies ahead answer revised our
search areas so we searched a particular
area that answer asked us to today
unfortunately with the weather
conditions as you experienced from the
flight we're unable to locate any
wreckage or debris but other aircraft
are continuing research up to last night
if this sighting does prove to be
conclusive then the search for answers
can really begin how and why did flight
mh370 end up here thousands of miles off
its original flight path those crucial
questions can only be answered if the
planes black box recorder can be found
but to locate the black box the search
teams must first find the debris if the
balance of water is obviously gonna call
to be damaged you know water if you jump
into it and you swim through it is quite
soft it's quite benign if you hit it at
high speed in excess of hundred miles an
hour you're hitting a brick wall and
that calls is the plane to break up now
Fraggles that plane if you've got things
like empty fuel tanks and I've been
flown that distance if this debris is
the plane they're gonna be full of air
so they're gonna float for a while the
wings will float for a short while
if they come away from the aircraft
you're going to get air pockets trapped
in part of the fuselage and one of those
will help the fuselage float but sooner
or later the air is going to be knocked
out of those and sooner or later that
debris is likely to sink so it won't
stay on the surface forever and this is
the race now to see if one can find that
debris before it disappears from the
surface standing by ready to be launched
is an American team with the technology
and expertise to search the seabed it
can deploy two underwater drones as deep
as six thousand meters they work in
tandem scanning the floor in a lawnmower
pattern 10 meters one way 10 meters back
it will go down a row it will turn and
come back down again on the other side
what it's doing is is that the side scan
is running and it looks out and is
getting returns back from primarily hard
objects that are that are on the bottom
all the rows in the in the mission are
put together in a created a mosaic and
you
and look at that and get an overall view
of the bottom and what what is there
these underwater drones were used in the
search for the wreckage of Air France
447 which crashed off the coast of
Brazil in 2009 even with a rough
location to work in finding it took some
time well over a year this scan
eventually led the team to it but they
need to know where to go where to search
if the plane has crashed its black box
will only emit a signal for a few weeks
more time is running out
it's possible that we'll never find out
what happened I think there just are so
many unknowns right now the issue of the
plane just flying you know without any
are almost minimal tracking for a long
period of time you know we need some
more information
this warehouse in America is where the
world's leading air crash investigators
piece together clues from bits of
mangled metal to determine how plane
disasters happen
their experience could prove invaluable
for Malaysian investigators if the
aircraft breaks the technical
investigation will likely disclose the
causes but if the human breaks the
technical investigation may actually
provide no answers as to what caused the
accident or the incident or the crash
next in part to the human tragedy some
of the stories of the men women and
children on board the flight who were
they and will they're waiting loved ones
Evernote what has become a food
we now have a credible lead there
remains much work to be done
we do have the pretty strong satellite
imagery and obviously this is a very
seriously
looking at an area approximately 1,500
miles to west southwest
a satellite image showing two objects
both big enough to be wreckage from a
crashed airliner but are these parts of
missing flight mh370 we do have pretty
strong satellite imagery and obviously
this is a very serious lead in the way
that nothing else so far really has been
it's very close to the predicted
southern flight corridor and that I
suppose reinforces our suspicion that
just maybe this is our the first
tangible evidence that we've got of what
might have happened an australian LED
mission is now underway combining assets
from the New Zealand and US Air Force's
scrambling to a remote part of the
southern Indian Ocean in an effort to
end the mystery of the Lost airline
returning back to radar to information
has been exchanged between the
Australian Malaysian and Chinese
authorities all desperately aware of
what this could mean to anxious
relatives for the families around the
world the one piece of admission that we
want most that they want most is the
information we just don't have the
location of mh370 our primary focus has
always been to find the aircraft and
with every passing day our efforts have
intensified yesterday I said we wanted
to reduce the area of the search we now
have a credible lead there it means much
work to be done to deploy these assets
and this work will continue overnight
the handling of the crisis has been
severely criticized fear and frustration
turning to anger some relatives of the
missing passengers were forcefully
removed from a news conference in a
kuala lumpur hotel
the scenes were undignified an inquiry
was launched
as the days go by without sign of the
plane or a clue as to its whereabouts
the uncertainty is becoming unbearable
for the waiting families they've been
avoiding their responsibilities and
talking nonsense there are a lot of
contradictory answers to our questions
that makes us very angry I'm angry that
the Malaysians don't tell the truth they
lie to the whole world
I'm totally frustrated about this where
is my son
even taxis have GPS they can be found if
they are lost or stolen it's a huge
plane so high-tech and so advanced how
could it not be found it's a joke we've
also learned more about the missing
passengers the personal stories of
flight mh370
the youngest passenger is two years old
the oldest 76 seven of them are children
yet to reach their fifth birthdays
twenty-six-year-old Yuwen Chou is
originally from Mongolia he moved to
study business at Hawley University in
England he went back to see his
girlfriend mikdash Mukherjee and his
wife Yama Bey had been on a beach
holiday together in Vietnam their two
young sons are waiting for them at home
could the flight manifest hold the
answers investigators are scrutinizing
every name on it they say they still
haven't received details for each
passenger after all this time the
passenger manifest is obviously very
important it enables you to identify all
the persons that are on board the
aircraft and that obviously is important
for the security of the aircraft but the
Chinese authorities insist they have
done their bit
China has investigated the backgrounds
of all Chinese passengers onboard the
missing Malaysia Airlines flight mh370
and has found no evidence suggesting
they are linked to destructive behavior
on the aircraft so we can rule out the
suspicion that Chinese passengers are
linked to a terror attack or destructive
activities on the missing plane
fifteen different nationalities were
flying to Beijing that night among them
153 from China 38 from Malaysia 5 from
India for French 3 from the United
States to Iranians on board became
initial suspects but seemed to have been
ruled out 35 year old Jew Kong is a
stunt man he was due to start work on a
new series for Netflix in Malaysia next
week he was on his way to Beijing to see
his two young children barbing Kathie
Lawton are from Springfield Lakes in
Australia they have three daughters and
they're described as doting grandparents
whatever the fate of flight mh370 the
pilots will have played some role 53
year-old zaharie ahmad shah was the
captain that evening
he's a vastly experienced pilot with
more than 18 and a half thousand flying
hours under his belt was a volunteer in
the community program that are organized
at the end of the program there was this
guy hoping to stack chairs to clean up
the place and not having met him before
I asked who is this man and I was told
he works for Malaysian Airlines I went
to say thank you to him and he
introduced himself he didn't mean his
name card and when I saw he was a
captain of a triple7 you know that's the
kind of humble person that captain
zaharie's captain zaharie's family have
made and released a video asking for him
to come home to them
he was hired by Malaysia Airlines
directly out of school and trained by
Malaysia Airlines he was one of the
original triple7 fleet captains you know
he's great guy
just a great pilot you know I think
attest to his experience of 18,000 hours
of flying great career the first officer
was Fariq Abdul Hameed he's 27 years old
and joined Malaysia Airlines in 2007 he
was fairly new to this model of aircraft
a Boeing triple7
200 the initial investigation indicated
was the copilot
who basically spoke the last time
do CCTV shows the two men going through
security on their way to boarding the
flight that evening
we're told they did not specifically
request to fly together
police have started searching their
homes talking to friends and neighbors
they found this simulator in captain
zaharie's house investigators say that
some data on it has been deleted
local and international expertise have
been recruited examine the pilots fight
simulator some data has been deleted
from the simulator and forensic work to
retrieve this data is ongoing his
piloting skills would be great you know
and and I think he would do anything he
could to preserve the lives of his
passengers and in the cargo the property
of noisy Airlines he was really proud of
that company and it took almost two
years for air crash investigators to
find out what happened to Air France
flight 447 it vanished in a storm in
June 2009 enroute from Rio to Paris with
a loss of all 228 people on board
Brad cleans seen here on the left was
one of those who died his brother feels
the Malaysian authorities should be
doing a lot more for the worried
relatives of flight mh370 but they don't
seem to be following some of the basic
principles again which is to have one
agency that's in control that gives the
information that's transparent and only
gives information that they know can be
verified and isn't going to be
contradicted the next day so you know
the families in that extent do feel let
down because they're not getting the
clear information they deserve some of
the Air France families have now written
an open letter to those waiting for news
of their loved ones on the Malaysian
airliner
we obviously feel a lot of empathy for
them we understand their situation
pretty well I would say that it's still
early days but they need to of course
count on the people they love the people
of their own family and their friends
and and sort of resem get themselves
together and organize themselves and
it's it is a bit early but it's probably
a good argument that they need to
organize themselves into some form an
association to try to defend their
rights and to push for the kind of
information that they require
it's heartfelt advice from someone who
knows exactly what they're going through
this mystery began with what should have
been a routine flight
now the search is focused thousands of
miles to the south of its original
flight to unidentified pieces floating
in the southern Indian Ocean wreckage
from flight mh370 or yet another false
lead in an aviation mystery that refuses
to yield answers and if this is wreckage
from the flight it will explain the
where but how long before the world
learns for sure why a plane carrying 239
lives never reached its destination